B/R BRGRIDGRIDIRON.
GET THE QUESTIONS IN.
WE HAVE TWO WEEKS OF PRESEASON
ACTIONBEHIND US.
TWO MORE TO GO.
HOPE WE'LL SEE A LITTLE MORE OF
THE STAR PLAYERS PLAYING IN THIS
WEEK'S ACTION, BUT WE'RE GETTING
THAT MUCH CLOSER TO THE START OF
THE 2021 NFL REGULAR SEASON.
YOU MIGHT BE DRAFTING THIS
WEEK
WEEKEND.
IF YOU ARE, I GOT YOU COVERED.
GET THOSE QUESTIONS IN.
I'LL BE ANSWERING THEM
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
I'LL GIVE YOU MY TOP FIVE TIGHT
ENDS FOR THE SEASON.
BUT BEFORE WE GET TO ALL OF
THAT, IT'S TIME TO TALK
INJURIES.
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF INJURY
UPDATES.
THERE'S SOME BAD INJURY UPDATES
COMING OFF THE SECOND FULL WEEK
OF THE PRESEASON.
LET'S GET INTO THAT.
WE'LL START WITH YOUR QUESTIONS
AS IT RELATES TO THOSE INJURIES.
THIS IS FROM BRIAN.
BRIAN NORRIS WANTS TO KNOW, WHO
SHOULD I DRAFT FIRST?
JULIO JONES OR A.J. BROWN?
JULIO HAS OBVIOUSLY BEEN ON AND
OFF THE INJURY REPORT FOR THE
MAJORITY OF HIS CAREER.
A.J. BROWN IS THE ONE TO FOCUS
ON HERE.
I STILL HAVE A.J. BROWN AS MY
TOP RANKED WIDE RECEIVER FOR THE
TENNESSEE TITANS.
COMING OFF AN OUTSTANDING YEAR
LAST SEASON.
AND WE KNOW THAT WHILE JULIO IS
GREAT, HE'S A LITTLE BIT DEEPER
INTO HIS CAREER.
IT IS HIS FIRST SEASON WITH THE
TENNESSEE TITANS.
A.J. BROWN, WIDE RECEIVER, SIX.
JULIO JONES, WIDE RECEIVER, 20.
BOTH TOP 20 PLAYERS.
LET'S HOPE THIS COVID CLUSTER,
THEY'RE CALLING IT, WHICH NOW
INCLUDES RYAN TANNEHILL, DOES
NOT BECOME A BIGGER ISSUE FOR
THE TENNESSEE TITANS.
A.J. BROWN OVER JULIO, TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION, BRIAN.
LET'S GET ANOTHER ONE OF YOUR
QUESTIONS IN RIGHT HERE.
LET'S TALK TO THE MAN.
THE MAN WANTS TO KNOW WITH
ETIENNE'S INJURY, WOULD YOU
SUGGEST GETTING IN THE JAGUAR'S
BACKFIELD?
THERE WAS BAD INJURY NEWS THE
SECOND WEEK OF THE PRESEASON,
AND THIS WAS THE BIGGEST PIECE
OF IT.
TRAVIS ETIENNE, HE IS DONE FOR
THE 2021 SEASON.
SO WHERE DO WE GO BACK?
WE GO BACK TO JAMES ROBINSON.
ROBINSON MAY HAVE TAKEN YOU TO
THE FANTASY PLAYOFFS LAST
SEASON.
NOW WITH MY NEW RANKINGS, HE
COMES IN AT RB-15, 27th OVERALL.
I THINK IT'S SOMEBODY YOU WANT
TO GET.
NOW, I'M NOT SUPER EXCITED ABOUT
THE JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS, BUT
JACKSON IS PROVEN.
WE KNOW TREVOR LAWRENCE IS THE
STARTING QUARTERBACK, AS HE
SHOULD BE.
YOU CAN SAY JAMES ROBINSON IS
THE SAFEST PLAY TO GET FROM THE
JAGUARS, NOW WITH TRAVIS ETIENNE
OUT FOR THE SEASON.
BY THE WAY, TRAVIS ETIENNE, A
HOLD, OBVIOUSLY, IN YOUR DYNASTY
LEAGUES.
BRIAN CLAY, BIG INJURIES LATELY.
WHO DO YOU SUGGEST WE HOLDING ON
DRAFTING AND WHO DO WE STICK
WITH?
A NAME WE TALKED ABOUT A LOT IN
THE FIRST COUPLE EPISODES OF
THIS SEASON'S, "YOUR FANTASY
FIRE DRILL," IS THAT MAN RIGHT
THERE, DARRELL HENDERSON.
SPRAINED THUMB COMING OUT OF
LAST WEEK.
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'LL BE A BIG
DEAL.
HE IS DAY TO DAY THERE.
THE BIGGER ISSUE IS THE FACT THE
RAMS TRADED FOR SONY MICHEL FROM
THE NEW ENGLAND PATRIOTS.
LOOKED LIKE A LOCKED IN SPOT FOR
DARRELL HENDERSON.
TOP 15 RB POTENTIAL.
NOW, YOU BRING SONY MICHEL, AND
THAT GIVES ME PAUSE.
I MOVE HENDERSON DOWN TO RB 21.
SONY MICHEL MORE IN THE FLEX
AREA.
IT TAKES A LITTLE OF THE UPSIDE
AWAY FROM DARRELL HENDERSON.
A NAME THAT I AND THE ENTIRE
FANTASY INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT AS A POTENTIAL
SLEEPER THIS YEAR.
ADAM TROUTMAN.
I GUESS WE ALL JINX HIM.
HE'S OUT TWO TO FOUR WEEKS WITH
THIS FOOT INJURY.
YES, HE COULD BE READY FOR THE
START OF THE REGULAR SEASON.
THE SAINTS, AS I MENTIONED,
OUTSIDE OF ALVIN KAMARA GAVE ME
A LOT OF PAUSE.
NO DREW BREES.
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT MICHAEL
THOMAS, IF HE'LL BE BACK TO THE
TOP FORM, IF EVER.
LOOKED LIKE THERE WOULD BE
TARGETS AVAILABLE FOR ADAM
TROUTMAN.
MOVING ON FROM OTHER TIGHT ENDS.
HE'S OUT TWO TO FOUR WEEKS.
HE IS STILL SOMEONE I WANT TO
GET IN BEST BALL LEAGUES, BUT I
THINK NOW HE IS MORE OF A LAST
OR SECOND TO LAST ROUND PICK,
OPPOSED TO SOMEBODY MAYBE YOU
WERE GETTING IN THE 10th, 11th,
12th ROUNDS.
MOVING ON, LET'S TALK ABOUT DAK
PRESCOTT.
HE'S A NAME THAT'S COME UP A
LOT.
WE KNOW THE NASTY LEG INJURY
LAST SEASON.
NOW, IT'S MORE ABOUT THE
SHOULDER.
MRIs CONTINUE TO BE POSITIVE.
ADAM SCHEFTER PUTTING IT OUT
THERE THAT, YOU KNOW, IT DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE PRESCOTT IS ALL THE
WAY THERE AND MAY NOT BE.
THAT IS GIVING ME CONCERN.
I HAVE HIM AT THE QB 6 SPOT,
THINKING ABOUT MOVING HIM DOWN.
THE SHOULDER, NOT THE LEG BEING
THE BIGGER CONCERN, YOU KNOW, IT
MI
MAKES ME FEEL A LITTLE BETTER.
PRESCOTT IS GETTING THE BONUS
WITH HIS LEG.
LET'S KEEP AN EYE ON THIS
SITUATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A LOT MORE
POSITIVE NEWS OUT OF DAK
PRESCOTT.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE GETTING
ENOUGH OF THAT RIGHT NOW.
LET'S MOVE ON TO CLYDE
EDWARDS-HELAIRE.
ACCORDING TO HEAD COACH ANDY
REID OF THE KANSAS CITY CHIEFS,
EDWARDS-HELAIRE SUFFERED A
SLIGHT ANKLE SPRAIN IN LAST
WEEK'S GAME.
NOW, I BRING UP SLIGHT, AND I
PUT THAT IN QUOTES, BECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T KNOW, NOTHING THAT
COMES FROM THE TEAM, OUTSIDE OF
THE PUP LIST, WHICH WE'RE PAST
AT THIS POINT, HAS TO BE
OFFICIAL.
AN INJURY REPORT THAT WE HEAR,
ANY INJURY UPDATES, THEY DON'T
REALLY MEAN ANYTHING UNTIL WEEK
ONE WHEN THEY'RE LOCKED IN.
YES, WE'LL SEE PLAYERS LAND ON
THE LIST, AND THEY'LL BE OUT THE
FIRST SIX WEEKS OF THE SEASON.
WE'RE NOT THERE WITH
EDWARDS-
EDWARDS-HELAIRE.
I'M SAYING, IF THIS LINGERS,
MAYBE HE POPS UP ON THE INJURY
REPORT.
NOT GETTING TOO SCARED HERE.
HE IS MY RB-14, 22nd OVERALL.
DeANDRE SWIFT, THIS ONE IS
CONCERNING ME.
I WAS ALREADY CONCERNED BY THE
TALK OF JAMAL WILLIAMS, THE 1B
TO SWIFT'S 1A.
THIS GROIN ISSUE IS A PROBLEM.
IT'S ALSO A PROBLEM BECAUSE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT IN DETROIT
THE CONDITIONING ISSUE.
SO A GROIN ISSUE CAN ALWAYS POP
BACK UP.
YOU CUT THE WRONG WAY, AND
YOU'RE BACK TO SQUARE ONE.
BUT THE FACT THAT THE TEAM IS
WORRIED ABOUT HIS CONDITIONING,
THAT TELLS ME WE COULD BE SEEING
A LOT MORE OF JAMAL WILLIAMS.
NOW, I HAVE SWIFT AT RB-17.
IF WE DON'T GET ANYTHING
POSITIVE IN THE NEXT WEEK OR SO,
I WILL PROBABLY BE MOVING HIM
DOWN AND MOVING JAMAL WILLIAMS
UP.
TALKED ABOUT JAMAL WILLIAMS LAST
WEEK AS A POTENTIAL SLEEPER.
GOOD NEWS, MORE ABOUT REALITY
THAN FANTASY, AS WE GO TO INDY
HERE FOR OUR FINAL INJURY.
THAT'S CARSON WENTZ.
CARSON WENTZ HAD THE FOOT
SURGERY.
NOW, IT LOOKS LIKE, WITH SOME
PRACTICE TIME, HE COULD BE READY
FOR WEEK ONE.
AS I MENTIONED, HAVING SOME
CONCERNS, NOT GREAT VIBES AROUND
THE INDIANAPOLIS COLTS.
EVERYTHING NEEDED TO GO
PERFECTLY FOR CARSON WENTZ, AND
IT HASN'T.
NOW, REPORTS FROM PRACTICE SINCE
HE'S COME BACK HAVE BEEN SOLID.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE IS PRETTY GOOD.
IT IS ONLY GOING TO BE A COUPLE
WEEKS.
WILL HE TAKE A LITTLE MORE TIME
TO GET IN STEP, GET IN TUNE WITH
HIS TEAM?
THAT'S A POSSIBILITY.
JONATHAN TAYLOR STILL THE ONLY
COLT IN MY TOP 100.
I THINK WENTZ, WHILE YOU WERE
NEVER TAKING HIM AS SOMEONE TO
THROW IN THE STARTING LINEUP,
THERE'S A LITTLE MORE CONFIDENCE
IN HIM AS A QB-2 IN THE TWO QB
LEAGUES.
>>> LET'S MOVE ON FROM THE
INJURIES AND THE BAD NEWS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT TIGHT ENDS.
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS THERE.
IT'S A POSITION THAT IS A BIG
TOP HEAVY.
BEFORE I GET TO MY TOP FIVE
TIGHT ENDS, LET'S GET TO YOUR
QUESTIONS.
J.DESIO SAYS, WHAT IS ZACH
ERTZ'S VALUE?
HE IS MY TIGHT END '21.
DALLAS GODDARD, OF COURSE, IN
PHILADELPHIA, MY TIGHT END 9.
IT WAS A CHANGING OF THE GUARD
LAST YEAR.
ZACH ERTZ, AND WE THANK HIM IN
THE FANTASY WORLD, ALWAYS TRIED
TO PLAY THROUGH INJURIES.
IT IS CATCHING UP TO HIM.
WE SAW IT LAST YEAR.
WE SAW DALLAS GODDARD PAST HIM.
WHAT EVERYBODY IS HOPING FOR IF
YOU HAVE ANY SHARES ON ERTZ OR
HOPE TO, IS HE IS TRADED INTO A
MUCH BETTER SITUATION.
NOT SOMEONE I AM LOOKING TO GO
AFTER.
IT WAS DALLAS GODDARD'S SHOW FOR
THE EAGLES.
LET'S MOVE ON FROM ERTZ BUT STAY
IN THE NFC EAST.
THIS COMES FROM EVAN INGRAM,
BASICALLY THIS EMOJI AS I'M
READING THIS HERE.
TIGHT END-16 TO ME.
NOT SOMEBODY I'M LOOKING TO GET.
NOT SOMEBODY WITH A TON OF
UPSIDE HERE.
THE NUMBERS LAST YEAR WERE
SOLID.
NOW KENNY GAL OLLADAY IS THERE.
SAY SAQUON BARKLEY.
INGRAM BENEFITTED FROM THE
TARGETS HE'S GOTTEN BECAUSE
OTHERS WEREN'T THERE.
WHEN OTHERS ARE AROUND, HE
DOESN'T BECOME AS IMPORTANT.
HE'S NOT SOMEONE THAT IS GOING
TO BEAT COVERAGE.
HE'S NOT GOING TO DICTATE
COVERAGE.
HE'S NOT GOING TO SCARE ANYBODY
THERE.
I JUST THINK HE IS KIND OF A
GUY.
I COULD SEE HIM PLUG IT IN, OH,
I'M STUCK THIS WEEK, TIGHT END.
I DON'T EXPECT INGRAM TO PUT UP
THE TOP TEN WEEKS.
HE'S MY TIGHT END 16.
NOT EXCITED ABOUT INGRAM WITH
THE NEW YORK GIANTS.
IS EVERETT A TOP SEVEN TIGHT END
WITH RUSSELL WILSON?
NO, I HAVE HIM AT 14.
YOU KNOW, THERE WERE SOME GOOD
THINGS WE SAW AT TIMES FROM HIM
WITH THE RAMS.
BUT HE GOES TO SEATTLE NOW, AND
WE KNOW THE TALENT THEY HAVE
WITH LOCKETT AND DF METCALF.
I STILL LIKE CHRIS CARSON.
HE IS GETTING OVERLOOKED HERE.
EV
EVERETT, FINE.
PICK HIM UP THE WEEK HE SCORES A
TOUCHDOWN, THEN CATCHES TWO
BALLS.
THEN HE IS OUT OF THE FANTASY
REALM AND SCORES A TOUCHDOWN
WHEN YOU NEED DK METCALF TO GET
THE TOUCHDOWN.
HE'LL BE MORE OF A THORN IN THE
SIDE THAN USEFUL FOR FANTASY.
I'M NOT LOOKING TO GET HIM.
TIGHT END 14.
THERE ARE BETTER PLAYERS WITH
MORE UPSIDE I WOULD GET LATER ON
IN MY DRAFTS.
LET'S GET ANOTHER QUESTION HERE
AS YOU ARE ASKING ABOUT THE
TIGHT END POSITION.
THIS IS FOR METS FOR ME.
THEY'RE FOR ME, TOO, WHEN
THEY'RE PLAYING DECENT BASEBALL.
BUT WE'RE TALKING TIGHT ENDS
HERE.
MARK ANDREWS, TJ HOCKENSON.
I DON'T LIKE ROOKIE TIGHT END.
PITTS, IT'S A ROOKIE, BUT HE IS
UBER TALENTED.
A TON OF TARGETS AVAILABLE IN
THE OFFENSE.
IT IS NOT A GOOD TEAM.
THEY'LL BE THROWING A BUNCH.
HOWEVER, HERE'S HOW I HAVE THEM
RANKED.
ANDREWS, FOUR.
PITTS, FIVE.
HOCKENSON, SIX.
YOU CAN'T REALLY GO WRONG.
I'M NOT REALLY SCARED.
ANDREWS IS CLEARLY ON THE BEST
TEAM, IN THE BEST SITUATION.
I THINK HE IS THE MOST RELIABLE
RECEIVER FOR LAMAR JACKSON AND
THE BALTIMORE RAVENS, AS MUCH AS
THEY ARE A RUN FIRST TEAM.
THEY HAVE SAMMY WATKINS THERE.
HOCKENSON, COMING INTO ANOTHER
SEASON, HE DID A NICE JOB LAST
YEAR.
YOU SEE THE ADPs ARE PRETTY
SIMILAR.
HOCKENSON WITH GAJARED GOFF, NO
MATTHEW STAFFORD, A STEP DOWN.
I'M NOT PUMPED ABOUT THE LIONS,
IF YOU COULDN'T TELL OVER THE
LAST COUPLE SHOWS.
ANDREWS, PITTS, HOCKENSON.
GOOD QUESTION THERE FROM MIKE.
LET'S GET ANOTHER TIGHT END
QUESTION HERE.
BEFORE WE MOVE TO STRATEGY
STUFF.
RAIDER 909, THINKING OF DRAFTING
KELCE FOR THE NUMBER FOUR SPOT
OVERALL.
OKAY.
THEN PICKING UP WALLER, IF
AVAILABLE IN ROUND THREE, FOR MY
FLEX.
STUPID GAMBLE.
YOU DON'T NEED TO DO THIS.
NOBODY IS TAKING TRAVIS KELCE
INSIDE THE TOP FIVE.
IF YOU WANT TO SAY I'M GOING TO
START MY SECOND ROUND, YOU'RE ON
THE TURN, PICKING 12 AND YOU GET
DAVANTE ADAMS, AN AUSTIN EKELER.
YOU COME BACK AROUND, START THE
SECOND ROUND.
YOU SAY TRAVIS KELCE, ABSOLUTELY
FINE.
NO PROBLEM WITH THAT.
FOURTH OVERALL, NO.
NOW, I WILL SAY THIS, IF YOU
HAVE THE FLEX, I DON'T CARE
WHERE POINTS COME FROM.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE DARRELL
WALLER AND TRAVIS KELCE, YOU
HAVE TWO OF MY TOP FOUR TIGHT
ENDS ON THE SEASON.
THEY PERFORM AS TIGHT END 1
PLUSES.
THEY'RE BIG-TIME PLAYERS.
THINKING ABOUT THAT, NO, I'M
OKAY WITH HAVING BOTH THE TIGHT
ENDS.
BUT I'M NOT TAKING TRAVIS KELCE
NUMBER FOUR OVERALL.
LET'S GET INTO MY TOP FIVE TIGHT
ENDS FOR THE SEASON.
HERE IS WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE.
A COUPLE NAMES I MENTIONED WILL
POP BACK UP.
NOT ONLY IS WALLER IN MY TOP
FOUR, HE IS NUMBER TWO.
KELCE, WALLER, GEORGE ANDREWS,
AND KYLE PITTS.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
DROP-OFF AFTER THAT.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT GUYS LIKE
LOGAN THOMAS WITH THE FOOTBALL
TEAM IN WASHINGTON.
WE TALKED ABOUT TJ HOCKENSON, AS
WELL.
A SLEEPER LIKE AN ADAM TROUTMAN,
SOMEBODY MAYBE A LITTLE MORE
BORING.
IS ROB GRONKOWSKI, PERHAPS?
THESE ARE THE DIFFERENCE-MAKERS
FOR ME.
PROVEN NAMES.
THERE'S LEAGUE CHAMPIONSHIP
WINNING NAMES LIKE KELCE AND
KITTLE IN THERE.
I LOVE WHAT WALLER IS DOING WITH
THE RAIDERS.
PITTS IS THE QUESTION MARK
BECAUSE HE IS A ROOKIE.
AS I TALKED ABOUT A LOT, THE
OPTIONS ARE VERY LIMITED IN
TERMS OF BIG-TIME TALENT FOR
MATT RYAN IN ATLANTA.
I LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY THAT HE
HAS THERE BEHIND.
THAT'S WHERE I STAND WITH MY
TIGHT END.
BUT YOU HAVE MORE QUESTIONS, AND
WE'RE GETTING TO THEM.
WE TALKED A LITTLE ABOUT DRAFT
STRATEGY SO FAR.
LET'S GET INTO MORE OF THAT.
YOUR QUESTIONS ON THIS BEFORE I
GIVE YOU SOME OF MY STRATEGIES
THAT I LIKE TO FOLLOW.
C RUSS 286.
16-TEAM LEAGUE WITH SNAKE DRAFT,
CUSTOM SCORING.
WHAT TYPE OF STRATEGIES SHOULD I
BE USING?
I WILL SAY THIS, WHEN YOU SAY
CUSTOM SCORING, IF IT FAVORS.
PERHAPS THERE ARE LEAGUES WITH A
LITTLE MORE.
MAYBE YOU MOVE A KELCE OR WALLER
UP THE BOARD.
TYPICALLY, THOUGH, 16-TEAM
LEAGUES, THAT'S AS BIG AS YOUR
GOING TO GET.
AT THAT POINT, AS SIMPLE AS IT
IS, YOU'RE TRYING TO GET STUDS.
IT'S BEST PLAYER AVAILABLE.
MAYBE YOU DO GO A LITTLE HIGHER
ON THE QUARTERBACK BECAUSE IT
WON'T BE AS EASY TO STRING THAT
POSITION, KNOWING 16, AT
MINIMUM, ARE GETTING USED ON A
WEEKLY BASIS.
MAYBE YOU DO MOVE A SUPERSTAR
QUARTERBACK UP THE BOARD A
LITTLE BIT.
IT IS AS SIMPLE AS GOING BEST
PLAYER AVAILABLE.
GATHERING UP STUDS.
TRYING TO FOCUS ON TEAMS YOU
FEEL GOOD ABOUT, TEAMS YOU THINK
WILL BE GOOD ALL SEASON LONG.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS YOU WANT TO
FOCUS ON.
THERE'S NO REAL ONE STRATEGY.
16-TEAM, DO THIS, THIS, AND
THIS.
YOU'RE REALLY TRYING TO LOAD UP
ON AS MANY STUDS AS YOU CAN GET.
THEY WILL BE FEW AND FAR BETWEEN
IN SUCH A BIG LEAGUE.
LET'S MOVE ON HERE.
SMD IS ASKING HERE, SMD 1025.
THE TALENT DROPS OFF IN THE MID
ROUNDS.
IS IT BETTER TO DRAFT RBs EARLY?
I DON'T THINK YOU NEED TO
OVERVALUE THE RUNNING BACK
POSITION.
I'M GOING TO GET INTO IT A
LITTLE MORE AS IT RELATES TO MY
STRATEGY IN A LITTLE BIT.
IF YOU END UP WITH A CHRISTIAN
McCAFFREY OR AN ALVIN KAMARA OR
AN EZEKIEL ELLIOTT, ANY OF THESE
BIG NAMES, A DALVIN COOK, TO ME,
THAT ACTUALLY HAS ME SHYING AWAY
FROM TAKING ANOTHER RUNNING BACK
EARLY.
I KNOW THE WIDE RECEIVER
POSITION IS DEEPER, ESPECIALLY
AT THE TOP.
SO I'D RATHER GET MORE OF THEM.
BECAUSE I'M GOING IN FULLY
EXPECTING THAT, HOPEFULLY,
OUTSIDE OF MY RB-1, I'M GOING TO
BE WORKING THROUGH MY RB-2,
RB-3, A FLEX SPOT.
THAT'S THE NATURE OF THE
POSITION.
IT IS WAY TOO VOLATILE.
IT WOULD BE GREAT IF YOU TOOK
TWO TIGHT ENDS IN THE FIRST
THREE ROUNDS AND THEY'RE WITH
YOU THE WHOLE WAY.
BUT IT IS PROBABLY NOT
REALISTIC.
SO I THINK IF I TAKE ONE EARLY
AND I GET ONE THAT REALLY HAS
MORE VALUE, YOU KNOW, I THINK
EVERYONE IS GOING TO AGREE THAT
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY HAS MORE
VALUE THAN AARON JONES.
THEY'RE BOTH IN THE RB-1 TIER.
THAT'S FINE.
BUT IF YOU HAVE THAT MUCH OF AN
ADVANTAGE, MAYBE YOU DON'T HAVE
TO FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE TO GET A
RUNNING BACK SO EARLY.
GOOD QUESTION THERE.
A LOT OF THAT CONTINUES AT THE
RUNNING BACK POSITION.
BOSTON MECCA WANTS TO KNOW, HOW
DO I ACQUIRE WIDE RECEIVER ONE
WITHOUT SACRIFICING MY DEPTH?
TALK TO THE WORTH PLAYER IN THE
LEAGUE AND MAKE A TRADE.
IT IS NOT THAT EASY.
ESPECIALLY IN THE PRESEASON,
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO BE
EVALUATING THEIR TEAMS
DIFFERENTLY.
MAYBE I DID A GREAT JOB ON MY
DRAFT.
OR THE OPPOSITE, I DID A
TERRIBLE JOB.
THEY'RE MAKING THESE MASSIVE
TRADES.
IT IS NOT EASY TO DO WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO.
I DON'T LIKE TO MAKE TRADES
BEFORE THE SEASON STARTS UNLESS
SOMETHING CATASTROPHIC HAPPENS
AND YOU REALLY HAVE TO DEAL WITH
AN INJURY.
TRAVIS ETIENNE, SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
I'D RATHER STAY PUT.
YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
ACQUIRE WIDE RECEIVER 1 WITHOUT
TAKING SOMETHING AWAY FROM YOUR
TEAM.
ONE-SIDED DEALS DON'T HAPPEN
OFTEN.
PLAY MIND GAMES.
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY, YOU KNOW,
LET'S SAY YOU'RE A COWBOYS FAN.
YOU HAVE A COWBOY ON YOUR TEAM.
SOMEBODY IN YOUR LEAGUE IS A
COWBOYS FAN.
YOU TRY TO PLAY WITH THEIR HEART
THAT WAY.
THAT'S THE BEST WAY TO DO IT.
YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
FLEECE ANYBODY FOR A WIDE
RECEIVER ONE.
ANOTHER ONE.
TYLER WANTS TO KNOW, RB IN ROUND
ONE.
RECEIVER IN ROUND TWO.
QB IN FIVE.
IS THAT SMART?
NO.
YOU CAN'T PLAN THIS.
THIS IS NEVER WORTH PLANNING,
FOUR, FIVE ROUNDS DEEP.
THE BOARD FALLS DIFFERENT WAYS.
EVERYBODY COULD BE DRAFTING WITH
DIFFERENT RANKINGS.
THERE COULD BE WITH THIS IDEA,
IF I GO RB ROUND ONE, SAY YOU'RE
PICKING TOP THREE, FOUR, SURE.
RECEIVER ROUND TWO.
WHAT IF IT WAS A RUN OF
RECEIVERS AFTER YOU PICKED THE
RUNNING BACK?
OR MAYBE THERE'S A GREAT WIDE
RECEIVER THAT YOU DIDN'T EXPECT
TO BE THERE IN ROUND ONE.
YOU SAY THREE, FOUR.
YOU CAN'T GO BY THIS.
YOU CAN'T LOCK YOURSELF INTO A
STRATEGY.
DIFFERENT THINGS WILL HAPPEN.
YOU CAN'T PREDICT WHAT WILL
HAPPEN.
IF YOU'RE PICKING IN THE TOP
THREE, YOU MIGHT GO, OKAY, I'M
GOING TO GET A BIG RUNNING BACK,
BE COME BACK AROUND.
I'M GOING TO HAVE THAT TURN.
MAYBE I GO, YOU KNOW, I GOT THAT
BIG RUNNING BACK.
I DON'T HAVE TO GET ANOTHER ONE.
I MIGHT LOVE A RUNNING BACK
THAT'S THERE IN MY SECOND OR
THIRD ROUND.
I MIGHT HATE IT.
IT IS NOT WORTH PLANNING THAT
FAR AHEAD.
YOU HAVE TO LET THE BOARD COME
TO YOU.
SOMETIMES YOU LOOK AT ADPs, AND
IT DOESN'T MATCH UP TO WHAT YOUR
BOARD LOOKS LIKE BUT IT IS
BETTER.
DON'T PLAN THAT FAR AHEAD.
IT IS NOT WORTH IT AT ALL.
ONE MORE AS IT PERTAINS TO DRAFT
STRATEGY BEFORE I GIVE YOU MINE.
THIS IS OE 509.
WHAT ROUND SHOULD I PICK UP A
QUARTERBACK?
I NEVER GET A QUARTERBACK EARLY
IN YOUR TYPICAL DRAFT LEAGUES.
IT IS NOT A POSITION I CONSIDER
UNTIL THE SEVENTH OR EIGHTH
ROUND.
I'LL LET OTHERS TAKE PATRICK
MAHOMES, LAMAR JACKSON.
I DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO
STREAM THE POSITION, BUT I CAN
DO THAT IN YOUR 10, 12, EVEN
14-TEAM LEAGUES, FOR THE MOST
PART.
I'M LOOKING AT QUARTERBACKS THAT
ARE IN THE BOTTOM OF THE QB-1
TIER.
WE'LL TALK A LITTLE MORE ABOUT
THEM COMING UP RIGHT NOW.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU MY PERSONAL
BEST DRAFT STRATEGIES.
LET'S GET INTO THESE HERE.
AS I START, IT IS STILL OKAY TO
WAIT ON A QUARTERBACK.
I HAVE USED THIS STRATEGY FOR
YEARS.
WHETHER I GET SOMEBODY I LIKE OR
DON'T GET SOMEBODY I LIKE, THEN
I'LL STREAM THE POSITION.
I HAVE ONE WON FANTASY CHAMPIONS
WITH McCOWN, WITH ANDERSON.
YOU CAN DO THE SAME.
A BACKUP QUARTERBACK OR SOMEBODY
THAT YOU WEREN'T EVEN
CONSIDERING RIGHT NOW AS WE SIT
IN AUGUST COULD END UP PLAYING
INTO A SOLID ROLE LATE IN THE
YEAR, OR JUST HAVE A GOOD
MATCHUP IN THE FANTASY PLAYOFFS.
YOU PLAY THEM IN WORK.
I'LL GIVE YOU ADPs.
BRADY IS AT 78 RIGHT NOW.
STAFFORD AROUND 92.
JALEN HURTS AT 89.5.
THESE ARE MUCH FURTHER DOWN THE
BOARD, AND YOU'LL BE FINE
GRABBING THESE PLAYERS.
TOM BRADY IS GOING TO PUT UP TOP
FIVE WEEKS.
THEY'RE NOT IN THE TOP OF THE
QB-1 TIER, BUT THEY'RE STILL IN
SOLID SPOTS.
ANOTHER ONE, DON'T OVERINVEST IN
QUESTIONABLE SITUATIONS.
I'M NOT SAYING YOU CAN
COMPLETELY AVOID BAD TEAMS, BUT
THE TEXANS RIGHT NOW, WHO KNOWS
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
DESHAUN WATSON.
NOT A TALENTED TEAM.
THE LIONS RIGHT NOW, JARED GOFF.
WE HEARD, YOU KNOW, EARLIER
ABOUT DeANDRE SWIFT.
AWFUL WIDE RECEIVER GROUP.
THE EAGLES RIGHT NOW, YES, IT'S
HURTS, BUT HOW GOOD DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT THE PHILADELPHIA EAGLES
RIGHT NOW?
WHO DO YOU CONFIDENTLY DRAFT
OUTSIDE OF MILES AND GO, THAT
PERSON IS EHELPING ME TO WIN A
FANTASY CHAMPIONSHIP.
THE JETS, I KNOW THE COACHING
STAFF PUT ON A PRETTY GOOD FIRST
IMPRESSION, BUT I DON'T FEEL
GREAT ABOUT THAT.
THE JAGUARS ARE ANOTHER I'LL
THROW IN.
TREVOR LAWRENCE.
THEY LOST ETIENNE.
MID-RANGE GROUP AS A WHOLE.
IF YOU GET ONE OF THE PLAYERS,
IT SEEMS FINE.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING TWO OR THREE.
LOAD UP TON CON THE CHIEFS.
GET A COUPLE PACKERS.
IF THAT'S HOW IT WORKS OUT,
THAT'S FINE.
IF YOU GET STEFON DIGGS AND
ALLEN, PROBABLY WON'T HAPPEN.
GOOD FOR YOU.
THOSE ARE THE TEAMS YOU WANT TO
GET MULTIPLE PIECES OF.
GUESS WHAT?
IF THEY DON'T WORK OUT, YOU'RE
GOING TO GET RID OF THEM ANYWAY.
DON'T FRET OVER THIS.
I'M TAKING A JOE BURROW OVER A
KIRK COUSINS.
ADAM TROUTMAN, YOU KNOW, LATER
ON THAN AN EVAN INGRAM.
I'M GOING TO LOOK AT A KENYON
DRAKE OVER SOMEONE LIKE A JAMES
CONNER OR DAVID JOHNSON.
LET'S SAY JOSH JACOBS IS DOWN OR
KENYON DRAKE CARVES OUT A SOLID
ROLE BECAUSE HE IS A GOOD
CATCHER.
DAVID JOHNSON OF THE TEXANS, IT
IS A BAD TEAM.
GIVE ME SOME UPSIDE LATER ON.
ANY PLAYER YOU'RE TAKING IN THE
11th, 12th ROUND AND BEYOND
THAT, THEY COULD VERY WELL BE
OFF YOUR TEAM IN THREE WEEKS.
SHOOT HIGH.
IF IT DOESN'T WORK OUT, THEY'RE
LOTTERY TICKETS.
GUESS WHAT?
YOU'LL THROW AWAY A LOTTERY
TICKET IF IT DOESN'T WORK.
FINALLY, THIS IS MORE ABOUT A
LONG-TERM APPROACH.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE WORKING ON
THE RUNNING BACK POSITION ALL
SEASON LONG.
YOU COULD COME OUT OF A DRAFT
YOU DO THIS WEEKEND AND GO, MY
RUNNING BACK GROUP IS
PHENOMENAL.
I'M GOING TO WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
TWO OF THE TOP THREE PLAYERS
COULD BE GONE WITHIN THE FIRST
MONTH, MONTH AND A HALF OF THE
SEASON.
THEN THE DRAFT MEANS NOTHING
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO WORK THE
WAIVER WIRE.
RUNNING BACKS THAT HELP PEOPLE
WIN FANTASY CHAMPIONSHIPS LAST
YEAR.
TOP TEN FANTASY RUNNING BACKS
FOR WEEKS 14 THROUGH 16 LAST
YEAR.
YEAH, WE WEREN'T TALKING ABOUT
THEM.
AT THIS POINT LAST YEAR.
LOOK WHAT THE WAIVER WIRE CAN
DO.
TONY POLLARD STEPPED IN LAST
YEAR FOR ZEKE.
RB-14 IN THE FANTASY PLAYOFF
WEEKS.
THINK ABOUT ANTONIO GIPSON,
JAMES ROBINSON.
MIKE DAVIS STEPPED IN FOR
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY AND PLAYED
AT AN RB-1 LEVEL.
SO THE RUNNING BACK POSITION
ESPECIALLY IN YOUR DRAFTS IS NOT
ONE THAT WILL BE SOLID AND
STATIC ALL SEASON LONG.
YOU'LL GO TO THE WAIVER WIRE
WITH RUNNING BACKS.
THE WAIVER WIRE IS GOING TO HELP
YOU WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
MORE THAN EVER, THE DRAFT, WHAT
IT MEANS TO YOUR SUCCESS, IT IS
DIPPED.
THE WAIVER WIRE MEANS SO MUCH
MORE, ESPECIALLY AT THE RUNNING
BACK POSITION.
THOSE ARE SOME OF MY DRAFT
STRATEGIES.
LET'S GET TO YOUR BURNING
QUESTIONS HERE, KIND OF A
POTPOURRI OF QUESTIONS, AS WE
WRAP THINGS UP.
COLLEGE BALL.
WOULD YOU DRAFT ADAMS OR AARON
JONES, JONATHAN TAYLOR IN A FULL
PPR LEAGUE?
SIMPLE HERE.
HERE'S WHERE I HAVE THEM.
ADAM IS MY -- ADAMS IS MY
HIGHEST PLAYER OF THAT GROUP, BY
FAR, BY A FEW SPOTS.
AARON JONES WOULD BE NEXT, THEN
JONATHAN TAYLOR.
ADAMS, AS SOON AS WE FOUND OUT
AARON RODGERS WAS COMING BACK,
IT WAS EASY TO THROW HIM INSIDE
THE TOP THREE AT THE POSITION.
HE'LL BE NUMBER ONE OVERALL.
ADP OF 8.5 IN THE SECOND HALF OF
THE FIRST ROUND.
A COUPLE SPOTS BETTER THAN
JONES.
FOUR OR FIVE SPOTS BETTER THAN
JONATHAN TAYLOR.
YOU DRAFT DAVANTE ADAMS WITH
CONFIDENCE, AT LEAST IN 2021,
BECAUSE WHO KNOWS WHERE RODGERS
WILL BE GOING FORWARD.
IN A PPR LEAGUE, I ACCEPTED A
TRADE WHERE I GET COOPER KUPP
AND EDMONDS, BUT I TRADE MIKE
DAVIS AND HIGGHIGGINS.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
PRETTY GOOD TRADE, I THINK.
YOU'RE GETTING THE BEST PLAYER
OF THE DEAL.
IT IS EVEN NUMBERS, THERE FOR
COOPER KUPP.
WIDE RECEIVER-16.
40th OVERALL FOR ME.
CHASE EDMONDS, 64th OVERALL.
MIKE DAVIS.
WIDE RECEIVER 24 FOR HIGGINS.
61st OVERALL.
EDMONDS AND DAVIS ARE CLOSE, BUT
YOU GET THE UPGRADE IN COOPER
KUPP OVER T. HIGGINS.
SO CONGRATULATIONS.
ON MY OPINION, YOU WON THAT
DEAL.
NOT OFTEN DO I LIKE MAKING DEALS
THIS OFTEN -- OR THIS EARLY, BUT
YOU GOT THE JOB DONE.
IT WORKS OUT HERE BASED ON WHAT
YOU'RE GIVING UP AS WE SEE HERE
WITH MIKE DAVIS.
I LIKE WHAT I SAW FROM T HIGGINS
LAST YEAR.
I THINK YOU'RE DOING A BETTER
JOB WITH THE TANDEM YOU'VE
ACQUIRED IN THIS TRADE.
LET'S GET ANOTHER ONE IN HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO NATE.
NATE WANTS TO KNOW, WILL ANTONIO
GIPSON BE A BOOM OR BUST?
MAY HAVE HELP YOU WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP LAST SEASON.
YES, WE MENTIONED McKISSIC
BEFORE, BUT HE IS FAR AWAY FROM
ANTONIO GIBSON.
I DON'T LOVE THE WASHINGTON
FOOTBALL TEAM, BUT THEY HAVE A
GOOD DEFENSE, WHICH MEANS GIBSON
WILL GET HIS TOUCHES ON THE
GROUND AND THROUGH THE AIR.
11 TOUCHDOWNS, PROBABLY A TOUGH
NUMBER TO REPLICATE ON A TEAM
THAT'S, I WOULD SAY, MIDDLE OF
THE PACK.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW, I
HAVE HIM AT RB-11.
LOW END RB-1 TO ME.
I LIKE HIM, GOOD PLAYER.
THE LACK OF COMPETITION AROUND
HIM IS A GOOD THING.
I WILL SAY, MUCH LIKE LAST YEAR,
THOUGH COMING IN WITH MUCH
HIGHER EXPECTATIONS, ANTONIO
GIBSON WILL BE A BOOM FOR YOU IN
2021.
NATE, GOOD QUESTION THERE.
LET'S GET A COUPLE MORE HERE
BEFORE WE WRAP THINGS UP.
THIS IS FROM XX NINERS.
IS CHRIS CARSON WORTH IT THIS
YEAR?
HEY, COULD WE PUT A LITTLE
RESPECT, NINERS?
HE'S IN THE SAME DIVISION.
C-H-R-I-S.
SPELL THE NAME'S MAN RIGHT.
HE IS A GREAT RUNNING BACK FOR
MANY YEARS NOW.
RB-19, 39 OVERALL.
CHRIS CARSON FOR THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS HAS BEEN A PERFECT RB-2
TO ME.
HE'S RELIABLE.
HE'S ON A TEAM THAT TRUSTS HIM.
RASHARD IS NOT VERY GOOD.
186 OVERALL.
CHRIS CARSON JUST GETS THE JOB
DONE.
HE IS GOING TO GIVE YOU SOME
RB-1 LEVEL WEEKS MORE OFTEN THAN
NOT.
YOU CAN GET HIM AS AN RB-2 ON A
TEAM THAT TRUSTS HIM.
I KNOW PETE CARROLL LIES ALL THE
TIME ABOUT HIS TIGHT ENDS, HIS
RUNNING BACKS, BUT CHRIS CARSON
REMAINS KIND OF SOMEONE THAT
DOESN'T GET ENOUGH RESPECT IN
EITHER FANTASY OR REALITY.
YES, I LIKE CHRIS CARSON WITH
THE SEATTLE SEAHAWKS.
ONE MORE QUESTION BEFORE WE WRAP
THINGS UP IN THE THIRD EDITION
OF YOUR "FANTASY FIRE DRILL" IN
2021.
DO I KEEP RIDLEY IN THE FIFTH
ROUND OR JOSH ALLEN IN THE TENTH
ROUND?
IN A VACUUM, THEY'RE BOTH
OUTSTANDING VALUES.
I'M ALWAYS KEEPING THE WIDE
RECEIVER.
CALVIN RIDLEY COULD BE A FIRST
ROUND PICK.
JOSH ALLEN, PROBABLY FOURTH OR
FIFTH ROUND.
CALLAN RIDLEY, NO MORE JULIO
THERE.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
JULIO MISSED HALF THE SEASON
LAST YEAR, BUT THE NUMBERS ARE
OUTSTANDING.
BASED ON ADP ALONE, 20.8, THAT'S
THE SECOND ROUND.
YOU'RE KEEPING HIM IN THE FIFTH?
I THINK HE COULD BE A FIRST
ROUND PLAYER.
IT'S A HOME RUN TO ME.
YOU CAN ALWAYS FIND THE
QUARTERBACK.
YOU SAID KEEPER.
SO YOU'RE GOING TO KEEP CALVIN
RIDLEY THERE, AND YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO THINK TWICE ABOUT IT.
BILLS MAFIA, THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION.
MAYBE A LITTLE HOMER THERE WITH
THE JOSH ALLEN PART OF IT.
>>> GUESS WHAT?
I GOT ONE MORE OF THESE TO COME.
IT'LL BE NEXT THURSDAY, 1:00
P.M. EASTERN.
WE'LL HAVE MORE IMPORTANT
PRESEASON ACTION TO COME.
CONTINUE TO GET YOUR QUESTIONS
IN ON THE B/R APP.
WE'LL TAKE YOU TO A FANTASY
CHAMPIONSHIP IN 2021.
I'M MATT CAMP.
THIS HAS BEEN "YOUR FANTASY FIRE
DRILL."